today I talk about little old ladies
luck and being a great right hooker
everybody this is gary vay-ner-chuk and
you're watching the askgaryvee show
episode ten what are we gonna do with
eleven I feel like I go right into the
questions and I feel like I want to
smooth into it I mean if you watched
Wine Library TV over the six-year period
a lot of you did I got the the upfront
you know kind of like the morning coffee
you know it was a big part of it and so
I just want to say hello and everybody
want to mention that I'm really enjoying
the comments and reading a bunch of them
in the YouTube section I'm enjoying some
of you who are ready stepping up and
engaging with each other in there that
is a double kudos to you and in general
I'm just really happy that you've
allowed me the attention your attention
to get all the way to episode 10 fun
fact
on the number 10 Santonio Holmes New
York Jets wide receiver was number 10
one time I was yelling Santonio Santonio
he looked up I quickly had to react I
did the ten which also for a wide
receivers catch the ball he did it back
to me I freaked out
Marin asks do you ever complain and
what's your attitude toward complaining
in business and in life in general Morin
I appreciate this question I'm curious
how much you know me or if you're asking
that because the truth is if you look at
my historical tweets hundred
thousand-plus maybe there's two
complaints you know maybe you can get to
three one of the people I look up to
most in the world
maybe the person I look up to most in
world time with my dad I know damn you
might watch us is my mother and hands
down and I mean hands down the thing
that I find most intriguing about my mom
and probably one of the things that I'm
most happy that she's passed on to me is
her inability almost to complain
I find it extremely attractive I would
tell you that I adore my wife for that
reason as a matter of fact Xander is
whining too much and he's only 2 and I
find it unattractive I'm very against
complaining I'm very put your head down
I'm very don't you realize you're
healthy like to me the only thing you
should complain about is the unfortunate
unlock of of health you know somebody
dying that you love in a car accident or
you becoming terminally ill after that
it feels controllable and so I I really
dislike complaining I try to I talk a
lot about honey over vinegar it's an
analogy I use a lot here at vaynermedia
I on positivity and so the way I deal
with complaining is I try not to do it I
try to educate and empower people the
lack of it's a it's um the lack of its
value I guess I mean I I don't have a
gear there you know when you go on my
gear like there is no like oh let me go
into complain zone to me it's a assess
figure it out and go directly back on
the offense I'm a very offensive player
complaining is the defense Robert asks
I've been doing a lot of jabbing but I
don't feel like I'm hitting much of
anything any advice I have advice I
don't know if you heard got a show
askgaryvee subscribe um so here yeah you
know here's my advice if you follow
boxing or MMA one would understand that
some people are great technical boxers
they know how to jab and when they land
a perfect right hook on somebody's chin
who wasn't even expecting it they don't
have the power to knock that person out
Robert
the truth is my man there might be just
a situation where you're just not good
at closing but and that's something I
want in you know not to pick on you
Robert this is something I want
everybody to hear you just might not be
a great saleswoman salesman to actually
make the clothes in fact you may need
two people this is something I haven't
talked a lot about this is why the
askgaryvee show is a good show it's
forcing
me to say new stuff I haven't talked
about and probably blew it in the book
the reason I pointed there you want to
show them d-roc they might be like why
did he point there is a huge Jordan I'm
kidding I'm kidding uh that was the best
you may need a partner Robert you might
be the greatest jabber in the world and
you may need a partner right hooker
right and so I just happen to be both in
one amazing body but the fact the matter
is you may need a partner where you do
the jabbing and she or he does the right
hooking Chad asks how do I get the cute
old lady who keeps accidentally calling
my house to stop Chad one thing I pride
myself is in is actually really paying
attention I'm really good at paying
attention to mannerisms I feel for the
room I also listen to words you said
cute old lady
which means you actually like it and so
what I would tell you to do is flip the
script I would say go on the offense so
the next time she calls why don't you
try to engage in a 25 minute
conversation with her and actually form
a relationship one that can go deep into
your heart and maybe bring value to your
overall soul Matthew asks is it better
to update your social networks once a
week with great content or daily the
poor content Matthew why does it have to
be one or the other why not both I am so
tired that people think that this is
kind of like the thing that pisses me
off the most
Oh Gary I see you hustle so much but I
don't work hard I work smart
well hey [ __ ] I work both I work
ridiculously hard and I work obnoxiously
smart and that is my answer to this
question why not just put out a lot of
content often that is quality why does
one have to suffer or the other
that is a mistake mentality that is a
middle mindset go all-in you can do both
I do
címon asks how much of success is
confidence skill and love
Simon the truth is you know and some
people don't like to hear it sometimes I
say I'm lucky and people get really
pissed a bunch of you will put in the
comments right now but the truth is I am
a lucky guy like I was born in the
Soviet Union I could have been my dad
who was born 20 years earlier in the
Soviet Union and wouldn't come to
America until my 23rd 24th 25th birthday
which would have put me far behind the
8-ball for what I'm accomplishing so the
fact that I was born in the Soviet Union
during the Cold War and happened to be
born during a time where Israel and
America teamed up to make a trade with
Russia for wheat
I was traded for wheat that allowed me
to get out through political asylum in
the late 70s and come to America and
live the American dream has a level of
luck right and so luck is part of the
equation now do I think I'm lucky I do
not think I'm lucky because the
confidence which is great parenting by
the way maybe a little luck in that one
could debate and definitely just kind of
the overall skills and the hustle which
is DNA I don't know if you can be taught
to work your face off so I think it's
just a mixture I always talk about a
great wine show Steve he loves wine the
one I always think a great wine is never
100% Cabernet never 100% merlot a nice
little Meritage a blend and I think to
answer your question I think it's a
blend of all of the above
some people look I think I make my luck
people like oh you're so lucky that you
got into Twitter and Facebook
I don't feel super trying to figure out
how I'm getting healthy that dude
uh-uh I love his role like he just
doesn't care
he really is like the only person that
doesn't care that's what I told him to
do um I think it's a blend of all of the
above and I think that that is something
that people need to recognize feel
comfortable with bet on your strengths
and execute Nick asks do you think that
Facebook is still effective even though
it's pay-to-play model and throttling
Nick I don't know if you've been paying
attention to what I've been screaming
about for the last hundred days but it's
called Facebook dark posts google it
watch it on YouTube punch people show
you how to use it not only do I think
it's effective
I actually think right this second as I
tape the show Facebook is the
best direct selling marketing platform
in the world think about what I just
said
Google AdWords phenomenal buying rebate
retargeted banner exchange on the ads on
the exchange incredible Facebook dark
posts where did the organic reach come
from in other places you didn't build a
website and like we're mad at Google if
you weren't the first result for a term
you recognize that it treated you the
way it treated you based on the quality
of what you were executing really no
different than Facebook plenty of people
getting tons of organic sure there's
some twinkling of the tools but that's
their algorithm no different than Google
you don't get organic free reach from an
email marketing campaign that you spend
money on buying the email list or on
banner ads or anything else you do in
marketing and so because it started as
an organic only platform and people
treated it like email and you thought
everybody who was following you would
see it doesn't mean that the emotion
that that went away doesn't mean that it
isn't great as a matter of fact Facebook
has never been a better product I just
believe it I mean I don't know what else
to really say thanks for watching
episode 10 of the askgaryvee show the
question of the day I've noticed the
last couple questions have gone really
the comments section has gone really to
the question and what I'm trying to do
we're very early here yes I'm one of the
greatest video bloggers of all time in a
prior life just kidding not really
but I need more feedback so I ask you in
today's question add a critique today's
show give me some feedback you keep
asking questions I'll keep trying to
answer them oh yeah subscribe
on this episode I'm going to talk about
humor billion-dollar ideas a tough patch